- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you very much for joining us today.
So we have the pleasure of having
both Professor Theresa Betancourt,
who is the Salem Professor
in Global Practice at the Boston College
School of Social Work.
She's also the Director
of the Research Program
on Children and Adversity.
And we have one of her
collaborators, Bhuwan Gautam,
who is the Senior Community Advisor
of the Bhutanese Society
of Western Massachusetts,
and an FSI-R Community
Advisor at the RPCA.
They're gonna be talking today about
Family-based mental health promotion
for Somali Bantu and Bhutanese refugees:
The results of feasibility
and acceptability trial.
- Thank you so much, Theresa,
and thank you, everyone,
in the program at Yale
for inviting us today.
It's really a honor on
this very momentous day
in the history of the United
States to be giving this talk,
especially to focus on New Americans
with a refugee life experience
and our work in community-based
participatory research
to develop an intervention
and to share with you
some of our early findings
on feasibility, acceptability
and where we'd hope to go next.
So I'm Theresa Betancourt.
And Bhuwan.
- I am Bhuwan Gautam,
and thank you for the
introduction earlier.
And I'll also let you know that
I am sharing a lot of my
lived refugee experiences
in addition to our
current research program
with children and adversity (indistinct)
- Thank you, Bhuwan,
it's such an honor to have you here
and to share this platform with you.
So I'd like to just give
a little more information
about where I'd like to
go with the presentation,
some background on
our Research Program on
Children and Adversity
and its conceptual drivers.
And then Bhuwan is going to talk about
the principles of community-based
participatory research,
and its use within two communities,
the Somali Bantu refugee community,
starting first in Chelsea, Massachusetts,
and then moving out to Louis and Maine.
I'll cover some of that,
and then particularly
from his lived experience,
talking about the Bhutanese
refugee experience.
And then we'll talk about
the intervention that we co-created
and our early findings on
feasibility and acceptability,
and a recently published trial
in the Journal of Adolescent Health.
And then we'll talk a bit about COVID-19
and how we are iterating and adapting
and using technology
as the team adjust to this global pandemic
and how to still serve families
in the community-based
participatory research
and intervention study.
So as you heard in the introduction,
I direct a Research Program
on Children and Adversity.
And in this work,
our focus is to really
understand factors and processes
that contribute to risky life outcomes,
as well as resilient life outcomes
amongst children, youth, families,
and their broader communities
that face adversity globally.
And the focus in this work
is not just on deficits,
but on strengths and capacities.
And in learning about
this sort of information,
we hope to contribute to
developing an evidence-based
that's based on local
strengths and resources,
and also helps us close this know-do gap,
that we know a lot about the
science of early adversity
and its impact on child
development and mental health.
But we still see very large treatment gaps
in low resource settings,
both the United States
and around the world.
And we need to be doing
our highest quality,
most efficient and effective work
in those low resource settings
to address racial and ethnic
disparities in health.
So we have a range of research
projects within our lab.
They sort of fall into
these three broad domains.
Parts of global work on
war-affected children,
we've had research projects underway
on the Ethiopia-Eritrea border,
in the Russian Federation
with the Chechen displacement
and child soldiers in Northern Uganda
and internally displaced persons.
And then for now 18 years,
we've been working in
Sierra Leone, West Africa,
building from an
intergenerational study of war
following a cohort of 529 young people,
including many former child soldiers
as they become young adults,
right now with four
waves of data collection,
and this has been funded by the
National Institute of Child
Health and Human Development.
And we now have 15 year follow-up
of this cohort just published in J-CAP,
which we're very honored
to have that opportunity.
And then we've been working
on other forms of adversity in Rwanda.
We started first on the topic
of HIV/AIDS affected families
and in partnership with the government,
as well as the World
Bank and others, USAID,
have moved towards a focus,
not just specific to HIV,
but on children in extreme poverty,
and using a family-based
preventative intervention
that's been adapted to focus
on early childhood development
and violence prevention.
And so we've just published the
pre-post results of a trial,
a cluster-randomized trial
of over a thousand families in Rwanda
with the intervention
we call Sugira Muryango.
And that actually
is the same family
strengthening intervention
that is at the base of the intervention
that Bhuwan and I will talk about today
in our project on promoting resilience
and healthy parent-child relationships
in New American families
in the United States.
And this work is sponsored by the
National Institute on Minority
Health and Health Disparities
And we've had an R24 as well as an R01.
And we're going to share
with you the early results
from the R24 and the R01 is underway.
So Bhuwan, I'll turn it over to you.
- Sure, thank you, Dr. Betancourt.
There is a background
image, as you can see.
A lots of the times
when I talk in this kind
of forums, people ask me,
what does the refugee camp hut look like,
the house look like, and
this is what it looks like.
In 2015, I went to a refugee camp in Nepal
where I became refugee
for 15 and a half years
before I came to this country.
And I took this picture,
which is one of my friend's
house and which is really small.
And that's really ties
into this largest humanitarian disaster
that's happening since World War II.
And again, that's going
in the middle of pandemic.
Look at this numbers.
Globally at the end of 2019,
there were about 80 million
people forcibly displaced.
And if you see
the number of children
living in the conflict zone,
which rose by 74% of the last decade.
So if you think the United States,
which we will talk about,
I will show you more data
about how the resettlement
landscape has changed,
and that really needs
additional interventions
to address the needs of
the refugee population
who complete the unique needs.
- Yeah, thank you, Bhuwan.
When we talk about the unique needs
of refugee children and their development,
their mental health,
we have to go all the way
back to Urie Bronfenbrenner
and think developmentally, ecologically,
we have to think about the
role of time and maturation.
So certainly, on to genetic
or individual factors matter,
age, gender, temperament, intelligence,
your genetic history.
But we also have to think about
what's going on at the level of family,
the nature of caregiver-child
relationships,
family functioning,
caregiver mental health,
resources in the family.
And then we can't stop there,
we also have to think about the nested
and interrelatedness of
the community ecosystem,
who else is available in
the life of that young child
in terms of mentors,
coaches, religious figures,
other supports, extended
family, peer group,
which becomes all the more important
over the process of development.
And then as we see in our country today,
all of this is very much
nested within the historical,
the political, the social,
and the cultural context.
And this also relates to
beliefs about reconciliation,
healing and moving forward.
So all of these come into play
when we think about
anyone child's outcomes.
Bhuwan.
- So if we look at the refugee
resettlement trajectory
as compared to last year,
not last, before the
current administration,
we used to have 70,000 refugees each year.
That's when the U.S. government
had the highest ceiling.
But after the Trump
administration took off his,
it was drastically reduced down.
And if you look at the fiscal year 2021,
which is 15,000 refugees, and
that's the maximum ceiling.
When you have people in the pipeline
and then they end up
coming less than the
actual ceiling limit set.
And today's election is going to decide
what direction the refugee
resettlement will take,
which we will hopefully
see a change in this,
but let's wait and see.
As I was mentioning before,
a person who was very young,
I became a refugee when
I was seven years old
and having to spend lot of time,
my childhood and then
adulthood in a refugee camp.
I was exposed to different factors
that increase the risk of
poor mental health outcomes.
And I'm coming to the United States
along with 100,000 other folks like me,
and not only Bhutanese,
but there are millions of
other refugees and immigrants
coming with these different
forms of hardships
they have with them.
So the data shows that
children in the U.S.
have very poor access to
mental health services
and situation has increased in refugees
from the data we have found.
- [Theresa] Thank you, Bhuwan.
- And also, when refugees
come to this country,
they have many barriers as
compared to the U.S. population.
For example, refugee folks
are really reluctant to seek out services
because of the stigma in mental health.
And also because of the language barriers
and cultural differences,
there is lack of resources
in the areas they live,
and most families are overwhelmed
by their own migration experiences.
Similarly, services access is very poor,
especially for children and families
may not be able to
recognize their own needs.
I mean, not to have clinical
access and mental health access
is what they had in their camp.
And when you come from a
place like refugee camp,
sometime being a refugee,
you don't even know what resource exist,
and sometime our parents even
may not be able to
recognize their own needs.
And they are unaware about the services
as the refugee and immigrant folks are,
they do not have high literacy rate
and the resource are so low.
And also because of so
many other barriers,
there are limited to referral networks
from school and pediatric, et cetera,
to address the needs of
our refugee children.
So when you see the trajectory
of the stages of the displacement
when somebody becomes refugee,
and then they go through
different stages of life,
for example, pre-flight, if
someone had, for example,
I can put myself into this
states that I was in Bhutan.
As I mentioned, I was very
young, I had to leave.
I was the first grader actually.
And I was exposed to the violence
and I had many other forms
of traumatic experiences.
When I came to the United
States, as I mentioned in 2008,
again, it was a new journey for me
along with my family to go to the place
that they don't even know, it's
like an unknown destination.
Even if they said United States,
that means it was
completely a foreign land.
Both of my parents are
illiterate in their own language,
and imagine about leaving a
country and going to a place
that they don't actually
know what's gonna happen.
And other resettlement
also brings migration laws
and acculturation issues.
It's a lot when someone has to go
and learn the new language and
adopt to a mainstream culture
along with the financial hardships.
But also to let you know that
there are protective factors
that refugee families bring,
which are really great in
terms of building together
as resiliency factors
from individual to family,
to access, to education,
and community ties,
ideological and religious context.
I mean, we, refugee communities
are coming from a low resource settings
and then having to go and reintegrate
and then acculturate with
the mainstream society,
sometimes requires lot of efforts.
And I think this kind of
collaboration and partnership
has really helped us to move forward.
And with these positive
protective factors,
researchers really have
to put this together
to build the intervention
that works for refugees.
- [Orazio] Can I please ask a question?
- [Theresa] Sure.
- [Orazio] Bhuwan, I had the impression
that Bhutan is a very peaceful country.
So I am kind of completely at loss
that there are refugees
from Bhutan to the U.S.
So if you could please
share the perspective
like what led you to become a refugee.
- I'm glad that you asked this question.
Thank you so much.
I know that Bhutan
says that it's the happiest
country on the world,
which you might've heard,
that's on these gross
national happiness, right?
But that's the other side of the story.
Now, the truth of the matter is that
Bhutan has forcibly evicted
over 100,000 Nepali
speaking Southern Bhutanese
from its country in early 1980s to '90s,
which I was gonna talk, but that's great.
Then I can skip later.
And I am one of those
people forcibly evicted
and became refugees.
And if you see,
that's one of the reason that we partner
with Boston College and
Harvard School of Public Health
basically to heal the
mental health problem,
the torture, mental health
problem that Bhutan had created
so that our families could be helped.
We have lots of people
who were the victims
deported by the Bhutanese
authority, Bhutanese police.
We still have families separated in Bhutan
who are not able to join our
families, they are in jail.
There is a horrible
other part of the story,
which I would encourage
you to look into it,
and you'll have a deeper understanding
about the plight of
the Bhutanese refugees.
- [Moderator] Thank you.
- [Theresa] Sorry, go ahead.
- I have a follow-up question about these.
So I was reading a little bit
about the situation in Bhutan
and the kind of policies that
they implement in schools,
it seems that they socialize children
since a very early age,
and the way they communicate
with the children
and they convey the
importance of being happy.
I was wondering,
how does that affect your
measurement of well-being,
your measurement of
depression, for instance,
which is so susceptible
to how you think about
your emotional states.
Do you think this
poses an additional challenge
for measuring depression?
Do you think that biomarkers
might be particularly necessary
in the case of Bhutanese refugees?
How do you think about that?
- Well, to tell you the truth,
that when I became refugee,
as I mentioned, that I was very young.
I really started to understand
the complexity of this issue
when I became adult in
a refugee camp in Nepal,
and I further understood
about my own rights
about not being able to
practice my fundamental rights
is something that I'm experiencing.
Whenever I go to the platform,
I talk about these issues,
when someone comes up
who have never heard about
the other side of the story,
but to go with the flow
of these presenters
and we have a lot to cover.
And Dr. Betancourt and I,
initially we were talking
that we might have to answer
some of the questions.
When you have something
coming up in your mind,
please continue to jot down your questions
and we will have the
question and answer session
to go through them to cover
the whole presentation.
- Yeah, thanks, Bhuwan.
And I think the question by (indistinct)
is an important one,
a little bit about some of
the formative work that we did
to make sure that our
measures were fit to context
and reflected sort of
culturally appropriate language
that is used by locals,
who may not have had the opportunity
to receive much education
and may not be literate,
but really doing a lot of formative work
in a community-based
participatory research framing
to learn those terms and make sure
that we weren't using stigmatizing terms.
And then the collection of
biological data biomarkers
as an objective indicator
is also very interesting.
Something we can talk about,
I think in the discussion a bit more,
because the ethical issue is also involved
in that trust and relationship
and communities, as you know.
So let me talk a little bit now about
just the co-creation process
of intervention development
in collaboration with refugee communities
using community-based
participatory research.
Bhuwan, do you wanna talk about
some of our different partners?
- I wanna talk a little bit
of the history of the project,
and accolades, different partners
involved with Dr. Betancourt and I
are having the opportunity
to speak with you right now,
but as you can see in the list,
we have several others.
For example, we have Maine
Immigrant Refugee Services
and Jewish Family Services
of Western Massachusetts.
And oddly, partnership that began
even before I joined Dr. Betancourt
with Chelsea Collaboratives and RIAC
and other academic collaborators,
both at Harvard University
and University of Michigan and
Boston Children's Hospital.
And our funding support from
National Institute of Minority
Health and Health Disparity
and Community Consultants.
We have fantastic collaborators
that are really helping us
to develop this whole research
and intervention project.
So that leads to real nice definition
from Kellogg Foundation.
Community-based
participatory research, CBPR
is a collaborative approach
to research that equitably involves
all the partners in the research process
and recognizes the unique
experience that it brings.
CBPR begins with a research topic
of importance to the community,
has the aim of combining
knowledge with action
and achieving social change
to improve health outcome
and eliminate health disparities.
So again, the CBPR engages researchers
and community members like me
to equitable partnership
to deconstruct the power differential
and also community members are
engaged in all the processes.
Let me give you some of
the features of the CBPR,
because this is a
process of power sharing.
We come up with the challenges,
and to address that,
we are focused on the strengths
to offset the weaknesses,
and community members
are engaged in each step
of the research process.
So CBPR is especially helpful
when working with a stigmatized community
or with a stigmatized topic,
because it allows you
to gain deeper insights
and lead enhanced understanding
that creates deeper buy-in
and motivation necessary
to encounter stigma.
So the advantages are to
increase the knowledge
and to build bridges and
enhances the research process.
So it might take a lot time and resource
to develop the partnership.
But at the end of the day,
we are thinking of building
the social capital strength
in those low resource setting communities.
As I can emphasis that there
is a limited implication
so far in mental health,
and we are so glad
that we are sharing our work with you all.
CBPR has promising approach
given the stigma around mental health.
And it's really important to
understand the local context
and language around the
mental health problem
that can improve the community engagement
and inform the intervention.
So our CBPR approach is
by refugees for refugees,
we have unique approach.
We have two community
board advisory boards,
one is Youth CAB, we call Youth CAB.
And in Youth CAB
we have middle schoolers
and high schoolers.
Because the research program
is for the children and the parents,
we continue to seek advice
from both children's point of view also,
and from the parents
who are the CAB members,
adult CAB members sharing
their feedback, the results,
which will help us
document their feedback.
And we will develop
culturally and linguistically
appropriate intervention
in our FSI module.
So community outreach events we have,
we try to spread the work that
we do as much as possible,
not leaving anyone in the community.
And also we have monthly meetings,
and I am one of the liaison with
Boston School of Social
Work with Dr. Betancourt.
And our job, and not only me,
I have other colleagues who are not here,
our job is to advise on our
social and cultural needs.
- Great.
So I'll give a little background
on the Somali Bantu refugee community,
and then turn it over for Bhuwan
to give a little more of a history
of the Bhutanese displacement.
So the Somali Bantu refugee community
is actually a subset of the
overall Somali displacement
and resettlement around the world.
The Somali Bantu peoples were
originally generations ago,
taken from other parts of Africa
and served as slaves in Somalia.
When the war broke out in 1991,
they were displaced along with
the broader Somali majority
to refugee camps originally,
and then also resettled.
Although the early displacement
were from Somali majority families
who had access to
education and connections,
but there was a decision
of the Obama administration
to take a large number
of Somali Bantu as well.
But their trauma history is quite high.
As you might imagine, very
little access to school,
historically, prolonged trauma exposure,
both just within their families,
as well as in the refugee camps,
Dadaab and Kakuma refugee camps in Kenya,
and have had very little
access to education.
So a lot of the women,
the mothers we work with, may
not have literacy in Mai-Mai,
it's mainly a spoken language.
And so English as a second language
or English language learning
has been very complicated.
And we'll see situations
where children are learning English,
but especially the mothers
haven't had the basics to
allow them to have a platform
to succeed in those sorts
of training programs.
We need a different type
of literacy education
and integrated approaches.
Overall, Somalis are the largest single
group of resettled African
refugees in U.S. history.
And then the Somali Bantu
are a subset within this.
In 2004, over 13,000 Somali Bantu
were resettled in 50 communities
across 38 states, United States.
So in Boston,
resettlement began the Boston
area in 2004 with two families
and soon expanded to over 400.
And then there was secondary migration
to states where jobs were more plentiful,
where housing was more affordable,
including to Maine, and Louis and Maine
being a very large population
of both Somali majority
and Somali Bantu refugees.
And there've been historical tensions,
but also a lot of shared culture,
history experience between
the two communities.
And many of our partners
are coming from both sides.
This project's mainly been
done with the Somali Bantu
because of the language and
the cultural differences,
but some of our greatest collaborators
are also majority who are
trusted by the community
and work very closely with them.
Over to you, Bhuwan.
- So I'm gonna provide
a background of Bhutan.
Bhutan is a tiny Himalayan country
sandwiched between India and China,
which is really isolated kingdom
of about 700,000 population.
And as I was speaking before,
Bhutan government evicted its citizen
by adopting ethnic cleansing
policy in early '90s,
evicting 100,000 ethnic Nepalese,
we call Lhotsampa, that we
speak Nepali language in Bhutan,
under One Nation One People policy,
which is also known as Bhutanization,
that targeted cultural and
religious and traditional
and majority were Hindus,
but also we have Buddhist
and Christians as well,
who were evicted.
And also our parents' citizenship
rights were eliminated
and we all were forced to
leave to neighboring countries.
And we had to cross
India to get to Bhutan.
And I remember following
the footsteps of my parents,
I was young, but then I
remember slipping on the woods.
It took so many days to get
there in refugee camp Nepal.
And in a refugee camp, we were settled.
This is one of the pictures
that I was talking about,
in this kind of setting
for 15 and a half years,
there was no bathroom, not toilet inside.
There's a lot of public health problem,
which I am able to recognize that.
But again, we got survived and I'm here.
That's why it's really important
to deal with the hardships
and problem that refugees bring
to address in a culturally
and linguistically and appropriate way.
And many escape the violence.
And at the time I became refugee.
When I was in high school,
there was a civil war in Nepal
that had affected many of
children in Nepal as well.
And there was really
difficulty, not even difficult,
I mean, more than difficult,
refugees are not allowed
to go outside their
refugee camps to school.
The maximum you could go,
I could go in my refugee
camp was 10th grade,
and you're done, no education after that.
Employment, forget about
it, there is no employment.
You have to survive your
life on the basic food,
(indistinct) provided by UNHCR.
And there was a discrimination
from the local Nepalese.
- [Orazio] Bhuwan, I have a question.
- [Bhuwan] Yes.
- [Orazio] What was the relationship
like before Bhutanese were driven out?
Was the relationship very
complimentary or like was...
I'm still in shock,
I had not expected that
at all from Bhutan.
- Sure.
I mean, Bhutan, it is a
monarchial system of government,
there is a king and prime minister.
And Bhutan had no problem before 1980s.
But when the Bhutanese people,
Nepali speaking people became educated
and they started demanding
about the fundamental rights
and it became a problem.
the community became target,
and also the other social
political influences.
Nepal was going through political reforms
as well as in India
and all kinds of neighboring
influences geopolitical issues.
- [Orazio] Okay, thank you.
- And Bhuwan's written some
very important commentaries
we can share with the group,
and there've been these
events in New England around,
Bhutan, the happiest kingdom on earth,
and not recognizing this
truth of their history,
it's much more complex than that.
- So there is increased
mental health problems
when refugees, they come to this country
due to the resettlement stressors,
including cultural adaptation, language
and overwhelming information, anxiety,
which is likely to remain
for prolonged period of time.
And the fear for future,
resettlement in crime affected areas,
and also refugees need to
compete in the job market
all of a sudden after 20
years of jobless life,
which is not easy.
And as you see in a Bhutanese
refugees context in the U.S.,
third country resettlement began in 2007.
And I was the first person
to come in Springville, Massachusetts.
Before that I had no idea
about what Massachusetts was.
In fact, I was told you
are going to Windsor Locks.
What is Windsor Locks?
I didn't even have internet
to look up Windsor Locks.
And in fact,
I found that it was the
place where the airport,
Bradley International Airport was.
People think that when refugees
are brought to America,
the problem is solved.
No, there is a lot of complexities.
And after Bhutanese
refugees came to the U.S.,
CDC published a report that
suicide rate among the Bhutanese refugees
was almost three times more
than the national level.
- Three times, times as high, yeah.
Very alarming rate of suicide
around the United States.
- Yes.
- So thank you, Bhuwan,
very important history
and also justifies why
mental health was of interest
when we invited the Bhutanese
to join our partnership.
And the partnership had
started back in 2004
first with the Somali
Bantu in the Boston area.
And so at that time,
I was working at Boston Medical Center
with Heidi Ellis and others
at their refugee center
for trauma and resilience.
And we had been contacted
by the Lynn Public
Schools in Massachusetts,
because they'd had a large
influx of Somali Bantu children
into their classrooms.
And there were behavioral
problems arising,
especially in the younger grades.
When teachers would ask
things like time to line up.
And Somali Bantu kids
come pushing and shoving
to the front of the line,
and the teachers felt that
this was bad behavior,
but these were kids who
back in the refugee camps,
those had been really
important survival behaviors,
if food was being distributed,
you did need to push to
the front of the line.
And so there was just a misunderstanding
between the two contexts,
the teachers weren't understanding
the children and the families,
and the parents themselves
didn't really understand
how to navigate the school.
So in Somalia,
it's respectful to turn your child
over to the mentorship of the teacher
and to not get in the teacher's hair.
So they weren't coming to
parent-teacher meetings
or coming to the school
and getting to know the school community.
And the school saw that
as them being disengaged,
but really they were
trying to be respectful.
So there was a big disconnect happening.
And we were asked to come in
and do some awareness raising,
which we did with the
administration and the teachers,
and also the community.
And at that time,
I met Aweis Hussein, who was
serving as a school liaison.
He himself was Somali Bantu,
he's now gone on to
finish his nursing degree,
and he's an amazing person.
And he helped us kick off this project.
We wrote some early
planning grants together,
and building this community
partnership, as you can see,
has taken time to get to this
place of having NIH funding.
But it started with this collaboration
to meet both community and research goals,
because we were interested
in risk and resilience
in more affected children,
including those who come
and resettle the United
States with their families.
So here's a picture of a Aweis,
you see him down on the
second row in the middle
at the Chelsea Collab.
And the Chelsea Collaborative
is an amazing place.
Chelsea is the city across
the river from Boston.
It's largely migrant,
very diverse community.
It's been hard hit by COVID-19 actually.
A lot of frontline workers,
a lot of people living in crowded housing
with food insecurity.
And this wonderful group
that Chelsea Collaborative was mentoring
the Somali Bantu Community Association
to become their own mutual
assistance organization
and to learn leadership skills,
how to write grants, how to plan,
which was really fabulous.
We'd go in and we speak Spanish first,
and then we'd be switching to Mai-Mai.
And that's really how this project started
with that leadership training
of the Shanboro Association
and the partnership
with the Aweis Hussein.
And so the early aim of the partnership
was to try to understand
the community situation
and its priorities,
especially related to these issues
of emotional behavioral health
and wellbeing of children,
and bringing up their human capital
and ensuring that they could thrive.
So understanding the nature of
the problems and its causes,
as well as what are the
strengths we can leverage
before we ever move to solutions.
And this meant we had
to improve communication
because there's such issues around stigma.
And so if we wanna talk
about mental health,
how do we start?
So we started
using methods we had used
in Sub-Saharan Africa
and Northern Uganda and Rwanda
using first free listing,
and then moving to key
informant interviews
and getting local syndrome cover terms
that were non-stigmatizing
for a range of different expressions
of emotional behavioral
problems in children.
And then using this information
to assist in planning intervention models,
because we could talk about strengths.
Bhuwan, do you wanna talk
about our partnerships?
- Sure.
As I mentioned before that
we have multi-sectoral
and multi-disciplinary team
members involved in this project
that includes academic partners,
refugee community, resettlement agencies,
which will guide the study investigators
in creating the shared vision
through this collaborative research.
So our CBPR team and the
community stakeholders
really foster cross-cultural collaboration
in order to drive research questions,
which will help us in the
delivery of the improved services.
- [Theresa] Thank you.
- So our partnership, we have values,
and our values
are really invested in
the refugee communities.
This fits in saying that give man a fish,
he will eat for a day,
teach him how to fish,
he will eat for his life.
By training the refugee folks,
you will be able to
prepare them for employment
in an effort to skill-building
in a low resources communities,
like one of them is
Bhutanese refugee community.
And after the research project is over,
the refugee communities will
have produced the experts
who will influence and inspire others
to go for public health schools
and also address some of the health
and public health problems
that we had never known before.
I mean, I came to this country in 2008
and work at the resettlement agencies
for five and a half years,
till then, I had no idea
about public health issues.
I mean, before I got
involved with the research
in (indistinct) Community Health Center.
It's a lot when a refugee community member
is involved and trained
in this type of work.
In a collectivist society
like Bhutanese community,
these skills will build
social capital resources,
which can be used
by not just the Springville
Bhutanese communities,
but the Bhutanese diaspora.
- So now I'm gonna talk a little bit
about mixed methods and
how we approach this work.
So this quote from Arthur Kleinman,
who's a very well-known
medical anthropologist
and psychiatrist at Harvard
captures what we're up against
when we think about culture.
And there was an earlier
question about assessment,
as well as then what you learn locally
to think about intervention development.
So as Kleinman states,
"We know from ethnography
convincingly that concepts of emotions,
the self and the body and
general illness categories
differ so significantly
in different cultures,
that it can be said that
each culture's beliefs
about normal and abnormal behavior
are actually quite distinctive."
So that's where we run into problems
if we just assume
the tools we use with Americans
or in Western populations
can just be given a forward translation,
and now they're going to
work with Bhutanese refugees
or Somali Bantu refugees.
So we really
try to go about this approach
in a very different way,
starting with the EMAC perspective locally
in qualitative formative work,
to understand local constructs
related to mental health,
to parent-child
relationships and parenting,
to protective processes that
are relevant to better outcomes
for children and families
that face challenges.
And then to use that data,
to select our measures,
adapt standard measures,
or where there isn't a good alignment,
create new measures
and test them through validity studies.
And we also now,
we're learning not just
about the problems,
but about the protective resources,
so the ingredients for
potential intervention models
that can help promote better outcomes.
And so that's coming into this phase
where we're informing
the intervention model,
selecting intervention model
based on that formative work,
thinking about fit to context,
and evaluate these interventions
using the most rigorous designs possible,
including randomized controlled trials.
And now in a lot of our work
in different parts of Sub-Saharan Africa.
And even now the second
stage, R01 of this project,
looking at implementation
science questions.
So hybrid designs where we're
looking at effectiveness,
but also testing strategies
for quality improvement,
fidelity monitoring, and scaling out.
So we talked a little bit about
some of the formative work.
If you're interested,
there's a really tremendous
amount of detail in this paper,
we published back in 2015
in the American Journal of Public Health.
And this represented
our community-based participatory research
in the two communities
and how we got at those local terms.
We're talking in a non-stigmatizing
way about mental health.
And based on that,
we also did work on the
protective resources.
And this work got some
really wonderful attention.
We made the cover of the Harvard Magazine
back when I was at Harvard for many years
before professorship at Boston College.
And also we were able to
have our refugee team come
and help us disseminate the results,
the early formative work
and what we were learning
about youth issues
at Chelsea City Hall,
with policy makers and leaders
there in the community.
And so now I wanna talk
about moving from that data
to intervention, co-creation
and co-development,
and talk about the family
strengthening intervention.
Some of you may know the work
of Dr. William Beardslee,
his original intervention
was developed for the
prevention of depression
and the offspring of depressed caregivers.
After the formative work,
and after looking at
different intervention models
that could be done by lay people
that were strengths-based,
that really had a focus on families
and their functioning
as a way of promoting
wellbeing in the children,
we saw tremendous
alignment and opportunity
with Beards' model.
We had been working with Bear in Rwanda
on adapting this for
HIV effected families.
And then we had this aha moment of
'Goodness, this is working
in Sub-Saharan Africa,
we're working with Somali Bantu refugees
back in the Boston area.
Maybe this could also work
well with the diaspora
resettling New Americans, the
refugees back in New England."
And so that was the initial idea.
And we saw this as an exciting opportunity
to think about making it a fit
to the setting and the context
of refugee families resettled
in the United States.
So the conceptual model,
and what I also wanna mention
when it comes to implementation science
is that Bear's family talk intervention
is registered in the
National Registry of Effective
Programs and Practices.
So it has a pretty broad evidence-based.
And in Rwanda, we adapted it more broadly,
not just to depression,
but to other mental health
problems in children.
And that was sort of the idea here too,
because distressed refugee children,
doesn't only present in the
form of depression, although,
it can also show up in
conduct problems, anxiety.
So we wanted to think
broadly about mental health
and promoting mental health.
And so the conceptual model here is
we're working with refugee families
that have this history of past trauma,
as well as the resettlement
and acculturative stressors
that you've heard about from Bhuwan.
Some of the risk factors
that we learn about in our formative work
were just limited access to services,
not even knowing much about mental health
or understanding how to navigate
and get help for the family,
get help for children.
Lots of misunderstandings,
as you heard about the
U.S. education system,
also social services.
We can tell you all sorts of
stories about misunderstanding,
about child protective services or 911,
and all those interactions,
and a lot of fear.
And then just communication breakdowns.
As I mentioned,
oftentimes you'll have children
who are quickly learning English
because they're growing
up in U.S. culture,
and then you've got a mother and parents
who are coming from a
very different background
and may not even have the ability
to speak the same language
in the same household.
And so, of course, as you might imagine,
we have issues of
intergenerational conflict,
where there's a lot of
tension and poor communication
between children and their caregivers.
And so the core intervention components
building out on those models
were first this navigation role,
because this is done by
refugees for refugees,
with home visitors being
from the community,
they can help them navigate
both the formal systems,
like understanding the educational system,
child protective services,
medical care, insurance,
but also informal supports,
like getting additional
supports from friends,
from neighbors, from
community associations.
And as you heard
in the protective
processes Bhuwan discussed,
those mutual assistance organizations
are so critical,
and the community trust
and community leaders like
Bhuwan are so critical.
And then a lot of work
on just understanding the
U.S. education system.
And we've been focused really
on school and these children
in this phase of the intervention.
Although we do want to eventually work
towards early childhood
development as a target.
And a lovely part of Beard model,
which has a nice fit for
trauma affected populations
is the family narrative.
And this is a chance for the family
to tell the story of their
experience as a family
at their own pace with their own content.
And it's not meant
to focus on retelling
past traumatic events,
but really to focus on the
strengths along the way,
in the joys, as well as
the difficult events,
what helped you make it through that time?
And then where did you come from?
What have you been through
and where are you going?
It look towards the future
and a hope for the future,
which is so critical to help
refugee families thrive.
And then also just developing
positive parenting skills,
thinking about routines,
thinking about improving communication,
thinking about natural consequences,
spending time together,
that's productive and positive.
Those are all a part
of additional supports
that parents are getting,
with the intention being
to improve the parent-child relationship,
but also diminish
risk of mental health
problems in children,
which we know are elevated
in refugee children.
So as you've heard, it's
a strengths-based model,
it was meant to be brief,
can be done by lay workers,
it's prevention.
We're not doing in-depth treatment.
And the idea here is to recognize
and build on existing family
strengths to enhance resilience
and to use those protective resources
as the active ingredients
in promoting mental health in children.
And so it follows a manualized protocol.
We have weekly meetings
between the family and the home visitor
who's from the community,
speaks their language,
knows their culture.
And we have separate sessions
for children and adults.
The early sessions
are really at understanding
that particular family
and its unique challenges and strengths,
and then telling that family narrative
from the perspective of the caregivers,
but also then from the
perspective of the children,
and then moving through
the different skills
and bringing it all together
with a family meeting,
which is also
a very critical component
of Beard intervention.
And these family meetings
are something that
families may go on to do
after the brief preventative intervention.
So we're gonna share with
you some initial results
from the NIMHD funded R24,
which was a pilot grant,
to really look at
feasibility, acceptability,
it's underpowered to get
huge statistical results.
We're in that trial now.
But the intention was
to enroll 80 families,
40 from each community, have
pre and post-assessment,
and have a randomization.
There are good usual care
services in these communities.
And so it just like a lottery,
some families, in addition to usual care
would get the home visitor.
And then all along the
way you heard from Bhuwan
about the importance of our
community advisory board.
So whenever we had hit
snags or needed input,
especially in the
intervention development,
but also as we went, giving
updates and getting feedback
from the community advisory
boards in a CBPR manner,
and documenting that in a
process evaluation as we go.
And this is all guided
by an implementation science
framework that we call EPIS,
that really looks at these
different phases of exploration,
preparation after the intervention,
actual studying of the implementation,
and then questions towards sustainment,
and thinking about these bridging factors
between the community,
between the actual features,
the inner context of the intervention,
how hard it is to do,
the materials we use,
making it more easy to use
than the outer context,
the funding, the policy context,
and all of that's ever changing.
So in the data I'll show you today,
the main research questions
were understanding, one...
I'm gonna show you the qual data,
and then a little bit of the quant data.
And we also are working on
a mixed methods paper now,
where we synthesize those.
But the questions were how
acceptable and feasible
is the family strengthening
intervention for refugee
families or FSI-R?
And what contributes to that?
What kind of changes if any,
do caregivers and children
observe in themselves and their families
from the intervention participation,
and what perspectives do they have
for improving this intervention?
And so I'll show you data that
comes from 36 exit interviews
with caregivers and with children,
that looked at those research questions.
These were double coded
and analyzed using both
grounded theory techniques,
but also thematic content analysis,
because we have some theory-driven codes.
And so our sample
is half and half Somali
Bantu, and Bhutanese,
10 families from the Somali Bantu side,
11 Bhutanese families.
And the main themes
when it comes to acceptability
and feasibility of
doing this intervention,
we're really about,
as you might imagine,
just scheduling as a
barrier and overcoming that,
but also experiences
with discussed the past,
and I mentioned that in
the conceptual model.
And the relationship with
the interventionists.
And so as you might imagine,
these are families that
are working many jobs,
oftentimes they're large families,
scheduling issues could be a barrier,
but home visiting really
helps us get far with that.
There was once a center-based
attempt at this intervention
that really failed because
of low participation rates.
And the participants share
that that intervention
has problem-solving them
with such an important
part of making it feasible.
So as this mother explains,
"They would call me beforehand,
make sure I was available
and I'd tell them to
come over if I was home,
and we have to do a lot of
double and triple checking."
The Somali Bantu mother
talks about the patience
of the interventionist,
how sometimes they'd argue
and he would tolerate them
and also was very flexible
about having to reschedule.
The Bhutanese father here
found it was easy and flexible.
Experiences discussing the past.
As I mentioned, as a
trauma-informed intervention,
this family narrative meant
that this was an opportunity
for individuals to learn
about the family history
and even for children for the first time
to hear about the history of their family
and how they come to United States.
But sometimes, for parents,
who'd been through difficult
trauma in the past,
just going back to any memory of the past
could be triggering or difficult.
And so we have to do
a lot of training with
our interventionists,
focusing on the strengths,
focusing on the journey forward,
and that they're here
today and they're safe,
and what's the future that
they look forward together.
And so here's this Somali girl saying,
"My favorite part
was when we talked about
my grandparents and stuff,
my mom never talked about them before,
and I like knowing about them."
Or the Somali mother,
"Most of the intervention was fine,
but the only thing I'd say
I didn't feel comfortable
is talking about what happened in the past
in Somalia and in the refugee camp,
life was it easy for me and my family."
Here's a Bhutanese boy who said,
"The interventionists
asked us about family,
what happened in the past,
all of that, I felt good about.
He asked about my birthplace
and everything after that,
I had forgotten a lot of things.
I got to know things I
didn't know because of him."
And so when it comes to
the relationship with the interventionist,
participants spoke very highly
of having someone from the community
describing them as respectful,
patient, understanding,
and seeing them as a
real source of knowledge.
And so the fact that they
were part of the community,
really contributed to the
acceptability of the intervention.
So here's a Somali Bantu mother,
"I think the interventionist
did a good job.
I can't see how anyone
else in the community
who'd be able to do that.
It was very helpful
to see someone from the
community work in the project,
and we understand each other."
Here's a Somali Bantu mother also,
"The interventionist is
to someone who understands
the dynamic and the
function of the intervention
and the Somali Bantu culture."
So when talking about the
impact on participants,
primary themes that emerge
relate to improving communication.
More positive time spent
together as a family
and also the relationship
between caregivers
as well as relationship between
children and caregivers.
And so for family
communication, we see that,
especially for Bhutanese families,
they talked about how the intervention
led children to share
more with their parents
and vice versa.
Parents took more initiative
to talk with their
children about their lives.
And for many Somali Bantu participants,
they talked about the
increased time together,
discussion time as a family,
but language barriers,
they'll continue to hinder
family communication.
So here's a Bhutanese mother,
"I learned that we should
not avoid children.
We used to do things in certain ways
because we didn't understand.
But now we understand that
we should talk to each other
and ask about how the
other person is doing,
who he's with, where he's going.
When I said
he could talk about these
things with his mother,
we still share things
between mother and son.
Now we know things happening
in each other's lives."
Or here's a Somali Bantu girl,
"Just to talk with my family was the best.
I never talk with my parents like that."
And sometimes culturally,
and especially, we see
this in Sub-Saharan Africa,
it's not typical that
you would speak directly
to your parents about your life,
and if you had problems,
you might go through an intermediary.
And we still respect a
lot of those approaches
when we help families problem-solve
when they're facing challenges.
But also just opening up
communication channels
has been a huge part of the intervention.
Spending time together,
they talked about enjoying time together.
This Bhutanese mother,
"I didn't know how to give
time to children at home.
I liked that, we learned a lot.
We got to give them time.
I learnt this should have been
like this for generations."
Or the Somali Bantu mother, another one,
"The intervention
affected family
relationships in a good way.
None of my children used to talk before.
Now we sometimes sit
and watch TV together.
I always remind them
about the interventionists
and what he told them."
Here's a Bhutanese girl, a 12-year-old,
"The thing that was really
helpful for our family
is to go to different
places, to make plans."
Now this is pre-COVID,
But there are still ways
we're helping families
think about making there
be really pleasant time
together shared as a family.
She talked about,
talking about very simple
outings to a park, a theme park,
a water park, they felt closer.
And she said,
"Before this, my mom and dad
had a really busy schedule.
They made more time for us,
so we had more time to
go out and be a family."
Relationships between caregivers.
So it's different between
these two communities,
but again, it's a small sample.
A lot of Somali Bantu
mentioned the intervention.
Very few talked about it
really changing the
caregiver relationship.
The Bhutanese stated
how their relationships had been positive.
but children really
did observe changes
between the caregivers.
Here's a Somali Bantu mother,
"I love my husband.
Was it supposed to change?"
Here's a Bhutanese boy who
said, what he observed was,
"Well, before my dad
just came back from work,
slept, said nothing to my mother.
Now he comes back from work
and actually sits down
and talks to my mother
how her day was, they talk to each other.
I think they found a better relationship
when they took part in the intervention.
I think they understand
and they like each other more."
So when it comes to
improving the intervention,
the kind of feedback that they gave
were one about seeking tangible skills,
which you can imagine, illiteracy, jobs,
these things still really matter.
And also moving from a family focus,
also to think about,
how can there be more
leverage of the strengths
in the communities.
So seeking tangible skills.
Even though the intervention
was doing really exciting
things on the family dynamics,
they talked about so many
other services they need.
And you see this from
the Somali Bantu mother,
"I think you need to start services
for the people like English classes,
parenting classes, youth
group for both boys and girls,
parent groups, money saving programs."
Here's a Bhutanese father
talking about disability,
which was pretty high within
the Bhutanese community,
and remains to be a dynamic
of the resettled populations
we're working with.
And also alcohol abuse being
another important topic.
Whether connecting them to the services
or some financial assistance or education
and transporting them,
those are all things that
Bhutanese parents were feeling
they still needed attention to.
Here's a Bhutanese boy,
"My mom and dad can't speak English.
If they need to go to the hospital,
you need to be able to speak English.
So to help our parents with their English,
that would help us a lot."
And then we saw this dynamic,
especially coming from the youth,
to talk about
how can we also do things
at the community level?
So here's the Bhutanese girl,
"If there was a hall for
children to come together
to play, dance, talk, learn
Nepali language and culture,
we can't afford that for our kids."
Or this young boy,
"Services like youth
groups or women's groups
or men's groups or couples groups
to bring the community together
at least once a month or
twice would be great."
And that's why our community meetings
are oftentimes an event with food.
We've had cultural events together,
and that's why working with
community leaders like Bhuwan
is so important for hearing
this kind of feedback,
and for them to think
about what they can do
with those requests from the community.
When it comes to the quantitative results,
and these are just published
in the Journal of Adolescent
Health if you're interested.
With this pre to post-data collection,
we did see in the children,
a significant reduction in
those getting the intervention
and their reports of
traumatic stress reactions.
We also saw from caregiver reports,
fewer child depression symptoms
reported by caregivers
for both communities.
And then conduct problems,
kind of both ways,
for the Bhutanese,
we saw a significant reduction
in this small sample in conduct problems,
but for the Somali Bantu,
we actually saw that
it looked higher in
the intervention group.
So some of that
could be due to variability
and small samples.
But definitely the general trend
is there are exciting shifts
in child mental health
in the small sample.
We also saw in the Bhutanese
side of the equation,
a report in reductions in family arguing.
And when it came
to feasibility and acceptability
for both communities,
extremely high reports of feasibility
and also high reports of
satisfaction and acceptability.
And so future steps.
And I wanna make sure that
we have a little time to talk about COVID.
As you might imagine,
and as Bhuwan mentioned
at our introduction,
the policy and the political
landscape are ever shifting.
If you can imagine what this
project has seen in the years,
it started from 2004, 2005 to 2020,
a lot of shifts in policy
funding, resettlement dynamics.
When we originally developed this
being done by community lay workers
or community health worker provisions
within the Affordable Care Act
and also provisions for
prevention services,
were really a big part of our vision
for how we might have this
scalable and reimbursable,
should it be evidence-based,
should it continue to
show an evidence-based.
And that's meant we had to really focus
on state level policies
in Massachusetts and Maine
around prevention services
and what's reimbursable
and who the delivery agents
can be, including lay workers,
and we need more on,
is it truly effective?
And that's why we're finishing now
a well-powered effectiveness study,
as well as the process evaluation
steps we've talked about.
So Bhuwan, I'll turn it back
to you to talk about COVID-19.
- [Orazio] Theresa, can I
ask a couple of questions,
or should we wait to the end?
- [Orazio] You can ask them now.
Is that Orazio?
- [Orazio] Yeah, it is me.
- [Theresa] Great.
- [Orazio] But I am happy
either way, if you wanna-
- We're almost done.
Let us finish these last slides
and then we'll just open it up.
- [Orazio] Okay.
- Due to COVID, it's really challenging.
Before COVID we used to
collect our data in-person,
now with the COVID we are
collecting data remotely,
and our bilingual, bicultural
Nepali speaking trend,
family strengthening intervention staff,
they are the ones who
do the data collection.
Besides the intervention work
at the request of the communities
we have supported in providing
vitally important public
health information,
especially around
debunking some of the myths
like eating ginger, garlic
or steam Vicks would water off the virus.
We were able to bring
epidemiologists and researchers
and conducted those information
session and outreach,
and provided education via Facebook Live
with live interpretations
for our Bhutanese population.
And our upcoming one
is about supporting the
students and families
in the Bhutanese community
with remote learning
during this COVID-19.
Parents are frustrated,
children are everywhere, it's a mess,
especially in our community
where parents don't know what's happening.
And with that,
I would like to turn it
over to Dr. Betancourt,
to talk about digital manual.
- Sure, thanks, Bhuwan.
And just on the Somali Bantu
side, it's interesting,
just their user preferences
and differences.
So Facebook Live makes
sense for the Bhutanese,
but for the Somali Bantu,
they don't use Facebook Live.
And so to reach those communities,
we're working with the
local community leaders
using WhatsApp groups.
They do a lot of psycho-education
out of their center,
where they're still in a socially
distant way wearing mask,
holding some sessions on
education for families.
So it's all about working
with the community
and understanding their dynamic,
their needs, their preferences.
And related to this,
as you can imagine,
trying to do the intervention
solely over the phone,
now that it's impossible to do
face-to-face data collection
has been really challenging.
What's really exciting
is we had prior to COVID
launched this partnership
with Boston College
Computer Science Department.
And Sunand Bhattacharya,
the Vice Provost for Design and Innovation
with a small internal Boston College grant
to develop a technology platform
where we could swap in the
language, the graphics,
to quickly adapt the manual
for different refugee groups.
And this was a part of
our scaling strategy.
And so with COVID-19,
new energy really came into
that process of thinking,
how can we use digital supports
for the community health
worker to do the sessions
in a way that's engaging.
And now we've really
started to focus on the
family-facing version of the app,
which would be done with a family together
using a tablet at their household,
rather than people on Zoom,
which we're still able to do
sometimes by phone, sometimes by Zoom.
But to make it more engaging
because they're getting
interrupted, there's lots of kids,
to use video, to use imagery
has been a really important
part of this next phase,
using human-centered design
and co-design techniques.
And the idea is if we
create using a platform
that could work on a
smartphone or a tablet,
now we have a flexible platform.
As you think about
the ever-changing migration
and refugee patterns
in higher income countries
where we can adapt these
interventions quickly
with new imagery,
with community-based processes,
to think about what's appropriate
in the intervention content
and have different versions of it
done by lay workers, that
could be readily scalable.
And so that use of technology
has been really exciting.
And right now we've got
a Somali Bantu version
and a Bhutanese version,
but you could see in the future
we could have Afghani,
Congolese, Venezuelan.
So that's a really
exciting new development using technology.
So just to wrap up so I can
open it up to questions.
I hope we've been able to convince you
that promoting mental health
is about also looking to
the health of the family,
and it's critical to longer term success
of New Americans and investing
in their human capital.
That to do this is really
going to take partnerships
and changing the narrative
to more of a strengths-based approach
about New Americans and refugees.
And community-based participatory research
is a promising approach
for engaging communities,
it's iterative,
there's continuous integration
of lessons learned,
but it also helps us to attend
to the concerns of community
as well as do very fruitful,
interesting research together,
and ultimately to arrive at interventions
that are acceptable,
sustainable, feasible,
and hopefully able to be scaled.
So with that,
I'll wrap up our formal presentation
and we can open it up to questions.
I did wanna mention that we are hiring.
So those of you interested
in this kind of global work,
both in the United States as
well in Sub-Saharan Africa,
here's the context, please
be in touch with us.
We're doing this kind of work
in so many different settings,
and we're just really
proud of this research
with our Bhutanese and
Somali Bantu partners.
Lot of references to our presentation
if you're interested as well.
So there you have it.
Now we can open it up.
- This is super interesting,
thanks very much, Theresa and Bhuwan.
The questions I have is
that I would be very curious
to see the quantitative results,
especially of the new study
to quantify in a rigorous fashion,
the impact on certain outcomes.
I'm convinced that
the emphasis on both the
family and the community,
I was very impressed by
what you've been saying
about the community meetings
and trying to involve in some
fashion, the whole community.
I find that very interesting.
And I would like to see
if possible at some point,
both the impacts on those mechanisms.
So what is the impact
of your intervention on
the community itself,
on how much people trust each other,
how much they collaborate.
And there are a number
of quantitative measures
that one can implement
and collect to do that.
In addition to that, I would
also like to understand
the extent to which
these community effects,
and these family effects act as mediators
from the final mental outcome.
And finally, in terms of implementation,
would love to see...
I don't know whether there is power enough
from the experiments that you're running.
But something that would be
very interesting would be to,
especially with COVID,
especially with thinking
of how to run interventions
with limited amount of resources,
it would be really interesting to think of
what aspect of the
interventions are crucial,
are key to obtain certain
effects, and therefore...
But in order to do that,
you would have to have
variability within the treatment
groups in those aspects.
And sometimes, you can make
a virtue of some problems.
So supposedly have some locations
where the people running are
of higher quality, whatever,
or you can randomly variate
some aspects of the interventions.
And I'll stop here.
- Yeah, no,
these are all really important
methodological issues,
and it's exactly why Bhuwan is
now applying to PhD programs
to help contribute to all of the richness
that is still to be done.
Just to give some brief
answers on the methods,
and then Bhuwan should talk about
the lived experience of the community,
because he's certainly
more expert than I am.
But I absolutely agree with
you that there are designs
and measures that we can
do at the community level.
In my public health training
at the Harvard School of Public Health,
I worked with Tony Earls on his project
on Human Development in
Chicago Neighborhoods,
which is famous for its paper and science
on the measurement of collective efficacy,
which is a synthesis
of informal social control
and social cohesion.
And they had an independent
neighborhood assessment of that.
So it wasn't just self-reported
by people in the intervention,
but you could go door-to-door
and get a measure of it by neighborhood.
And wouldn't that be amazing,
should be able to scale this
to collect that kind of community data
with these kinds of processes.
Some communities randomly being allocated
to be in this kind of CBPR work
and others to be usual care control sites.
That would be fascinating.
And then when it comes
to the community effects
and family effects acting
as mediators, absolutely.
And that's sort of in
our conceptual model,
that we really see if we can
shift the family dynamics.
And that also means
their navigation of community
relationships and resources,
we believe by theory
that we can improve the
mental health of the kids
and see better family functioning.
In 80-family pilot,
there's not much we can do,
in the 150-family data,
once we get that complete,
we're about halfway there,
maybe getting beyond halfway there now,
but COVID has slowed us down,
we'll have a little more statistical power
to do those sorts of mediational analysis.
And then lastly,
when it comes to thinking
about dismantling studies
or isolating the active ingredients,
this is certainly a
topic of great interest
in evidence-based behavioral
interventions of many sorts,
mental health, early
childhood development.
How do we make sure we're
doing the most powerful things
and like removing the noise,
and then also thinking about
what works for whom
under what circumstances.
So what modules given a family's makeup
really need to happen with this family?
And we do a lot of this.
We have supplemental
modules that we may swap in
and additional referrals
that we often are making along
the process with the family,
and substance abuse being a common theme
that we've had to do a lot of referrals
or treatment for
post-traumatic stress disorder,
depression in the caregivers
or housing insecurity,
food insecurity, legal issues.
And so it would be very interesting
to iterate those ingredients
and use dismantling studies.
On implementation science,
we do have very interesting data
that you may be interested
in, Orazio, on fidelity.
And so our implementation science strategy
that we're testing
builds off of some of the work
we were doing in Sierra Leone,
actually using collaborative teams,
inter-agency collaborative teams
to enhance the fidelity
of the intervention done
by the home visitors.
Now we have a small, because
we have two communities,
our seed team of experts
are people who've done
the intervention before,
and they know it very well.
They've been through it with many families
and they then serve as an expert guide,
knowing the culture
and the language to
listen with permission.
We get permission to
audio tape their sessions,
and we have the home visitor
ask permission to the family saying,
"I'm learning to do this.
Do I have your permission to audio tape?
So that the expert and the intervention
can hear how I'm doing
and give me feedback so I can
do my best practice with you."
And oftentimes, families
are very open to that.
The recorder becomes a non-issue
when you're really focused
on the work with the family,
and then they're doing
targeted supervision.
So they may come back and say,
"Look, you're doing a
great job on this and that,
but here's some areas
I wanna focus with you
to prepare for your next session."
And using that
collaborative team approach,
we have team of experts,
and we're really looking at fidelity,
and we actually have
them score a checklist,
a fidelity checklist,
both about the session-specific elements
and the cross-cutting just
performance on rapport,
on relationship, on quality
that we have data on.
So I'm watching the time.
I know we don't have a
lot of time, Theresa,
and I want Bhuwan
to be able to speak about just
the impact on the community.
- Sure, thank you for the question.
That's what we have talked in our values
about the CBPR approach.
It takes a lot of preparation and time
to invest in a community
which has low literacy rate.
But again, I can give my own example that
I had no prior idea about
how to even to assess the
needs of our population,
of our own community.
Engaging people like me
and additionally other non-skilled people
to be community health workers.
And then maybe that kind of resources,
if we are able to
develop in the community.
And also just to let you
know that our community
is really a stratified society.
We have lots of classes
in all kinds of stratification,
and makes easier to engage them
with the different kinds
of background and those.
So we'll be able to take their viewpoints.
And also just to talk about
developing building that trust,
which is not easy thing to do
because refugee communities
back in refugee camp have
been not treated fairly
because of the politicians
and all kinds of bad experiences
that they might have had,
and unknown person coming
from the university
and majority of them are white
and they are coming
and asking about all kinds of questions
about their life background history,
even the political public charges
and all kinds of big things are coming.
It's really scary.
That is the reason we need to have real...
We need to find out
and reach out to the community
self-help organizations,
faith-based organizations,
to make sure that you work
with the community members
who are well known in their community
so that they can bring the
additional group of people.
And then we'll able to
do the research work.
Because it's really impossible
for researchers alone
to build up the
strength-based interventions.
And I think in terms of COVID,
COVID has definitely brought challenges.
And I think we really have an opportunity
to train our community members,
how to utilize first of all,
to train them to be
community health workers,
to do data collection and
research minimum level of training
so that they can have
the skill for their life.
But in terms of sustainability,
I would like to mention that
after the research project is done,
it's, again, Dr. Betancourt
has mentioned that
we hope that community
health worker services
will be available in the future.
And the state of Massachusetts
is really at the forefront
of the community health worker work.
But again, we are hopeful
that we will one day
be able to utilize the CSW services,
not only in the clinical setting,
but also in this kind
of resource settings.
- So we have run out of time.
I'm sure that both Theresa and Bhuwan,
if you have some more questions,
happy to pass along those.
And if you just join me in thanking them
for this great presentation.
- Thank you, Bhuwan, thank you, Theresa.
- Thank you so much for having us,
it was a great honor on our historic day.
Thank you, everyone,
stay safe, stay healthy.
- [Participant] We will.
- [Participant] Thank you.